Hello, and welcome to
Collab Week,
the week where I fulfill my
obligation as a YouTuber
to perform some "collaboration"
videos for your enjoyment.
In this installment, I am joined by heartthrob
disc jockeys Danisnotonfire and AmazingPhil,
and we will be collaborating
through the medium of sculpture.
We're going to
make some art now.
PHIL: Can I just throw a unicorn
into the mix? CHARLIE: You can.
DAN: You're going equestrian.
Something with four legs.
That's already very
advanced, Phil.
CHARLIE: I like unicorn.
Is there anything we can add to that?
DAN: I could take the black
and make it slightly robot unicorn.
CHARLIE: And...uhh...
rainbow colored.
PHIL: Rainbow colored.
That works.
DAN: Wow. Okay.
CHARLIE: How about a different
color for each body part.
Give it a proper squeeze
and a good roll.
PHIL: I'm making a hoof.
DAN: This is the first time
I've engaged my muscles.
PHIL: Charlie, our legs are
looking mildly different right now.
CHARLIE: That's not quite correct.
PHIL: Okay.
DAN: That's like a duck's foot, Charlie.
That's not much of a hoof.
Why are they so flat
at the bottom?
PHIL: That's what hooves look like.
Clop, clop, clop, clop. Clop, clop, clop.
DAN: Look, even if we don't say it, everyone
watching this is thinking the same thing.
PHIL: It's looking...
CHARLIE: They are colorful, phallically-shaped
DAN: Base complete.
CHARLIE: Okay.
DAN: Half pink,
half yellow body.
PHIL: Shall I start building
some kind of neck. DAN: Uhh...
PHIL: I feel like that's too much pressure.
I'm going to make the tail.
Is that what a
horse's tail is like?
DAN: They're more like down,
aren't they?
PHIL: Well they've got like a flare
at the end like a Charmander.
CHARLIE: I'm most impressed
by this tail so far.
PHIL: I'm proud
of the tail.
CHARLIE: It just happens to also be
the only think you can't see.
DAN: It's got the
shape of a horse.
CHARLIE: It has the shape
of a four legged animal.
Are we going to go
for red for head?
DAN: Red head,
yeah I'm feeling that.
CHARLIE: Does someone want to
bring up a photo of a horse?
DAN: Um...
No that's cheating.
PHIL: Imagine the horse emoji.
Like a simplistic horse.
DAN: Are you a fan of emoji,
Charlie, in your texts?
CHARLIE: I am. One of my
favorite emojis is the dancing lady.
DAN: WIth her little--
CHARLIE: Salsa lady.
DAN: Kicking out a
sassy heal.
CHARLIE: I feel like she encompasses
a lot of just general joy.
She's just having the best time,
and so if you're having the best time
you can communicate
that to people.
PHIL: Charlie, that
looks terrifying.
DAN: That looks like a horse
from Silent Hill. What have you done?
CHARLIE: I don't think horses have
quite as big necks as this.
DAN: That's a think neck.
CHARLIE: I'm pretty
sure we've made--
DAN: This horse is
on steroids.
CHARLIE: It's not unicorn yet.
PHIL: Oh no!
CHARLIE: We need the unicorn spike
on the front. PHIL: Uh let's--
CHARLIE: I think white's good for that.
DAN: Obviously.
PHIL: Oh that's good
twisting action.
DAN: Charlie's going in
with the twists.
PHIL: That's amazing. DAN: Man, that could
easily impale someone.
PHIL: I would buy that.
CHARLIE: Just the horn? PHIL: Yeah
LAUGHTER
DAN: What?
PHIL: I don't know.
DAN: What are you
on about?
PHIL: I love that this is
our collective skill, as well.
DAN: One object.
Are you kidding me?
CHARLIE: We now need to work
on the robotic paneling.
Do we have
any blue left?
Let's take a bit out it's butt
and put it in it's face.
Aww, look at that pretty
blue unicorn eye.
PHIL: It's horn
is drooping.
DAN: It's having
performance issues.
CHARLIE: So there we go.
There is our collaborative project.
PHIL: Yeah!
CHARLIE: Together, we created a
Frankenstein, rainbow, robotic unicorn.
DAN: Yes! PHIL: I love it.
Can we give it a name?
CHARLIE: Is it male or female?
I'm feeling female.
My instinct says Gertrude.
PHIL: Gertrude?
PHIL: Well, it's
also a robot--
DAN: That's the most inappropriate name
for a unicorn I have ever heard.
PHIL: What about Gertrude 3?
CHARLIE: Gertrude 3? That's good.
PHIL: 'Cause it's a robot.
CHARLIE: Yeah. How do you
feel about that, Dan?
DAN: We don't speak about
the first two Gertrude.
PHIL: Can you
now animate it?
CHARLIE: Neigh!
LAUGHTER
DAN: That's what it does before it charges
into battle and destroys worlds.
CHARLIE: Rawr!!
PHIL: Thanks for
having us, Charlie.
CHARLIE: You're welcome. Thanks for being in my collaboration video
for Collaboration Week, Dan and Phil.
PHIL: I had the best time.
CHARLIE: I'm glad you did. I'm glad
you had fun. I had fun. Goodbye now.
DAN: Bye, Internet.
CRASHING
DAN: Ow.
CHARLIE: Okay.
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.
CHARLIE VOICE: Thank you very much,
and if you'd like to watch
the other collaboration videos
from this week,
you probably don't need me
to tell you which boxes to click on.
I'm sure you can figure
it out for yourself.
Goodbye!